Karibu, and welcome to
Dar es Salaam in Tanzania.
I've just had one of the most
mind-blowing weeks of my entire life
hanging out with my mum and
with Save the Children,
and now I get to
tell you about it.
So first, I met a guy called Frank Kapeta
at his home here in Dar es Salaam
along with his little brother
and his father, William.
Basically, I was thrown into a world that is
utterly different to what I'm used to at home
and spent the first day feeling a
little bit shell shocked.
Frank is a pretty
inspiring guy.
He's 15, he's the young ambassador
for Save the Children here,
and when he was younger, he was one
of those starving kids in Africa
that we hear
so much about.
To be more specific, Frank used
to suffer from malnutrition.
So, he did have a little bit of food,
enough to survive,
but not enough
to grow up healthily.
As a result,
his growth was stunted
and so he's much smaller than
he should really be at his age.
And although he seemed to
me to be a very intelligent guy,
malnutrition also affected
his brain growth,
so he could have been even
smarter than he currently is.
The issues of hunger and
malnutrition are, by the way,
the reason that I'm here.
Save the Children invited me to come along
to support the IF Campaign,
which aims to make this year the
beginning of the end for world hunger,
which, obviously,
I'm in support of.
However, Frank isn't a
malnutrition statistic.
He's a person.
Like he does campaign against
because it's obviously an issue
that's very important to him, but he also
likes jazz music and supports Arsenal
and wants to be a journalist
when he grows up.
But most importantly, to me,
over the week that I've spent with him,
despite the language barrier,
he's become a friend of mine.
Even by the end of the first day, he was already
calling me, "my good friend Mr. Charlie."
So after Frank was nice enough to show me
and my mum around his house
where his dad works shining shoes
and his school as well,
we all got on this
tiny little plane,
the smallest plane I've ever been
on in my entire life, to Tanga,
and we traveled to the region of
Korogwe to visit a couple of villages
where the rest of Frank's family live
and where he grew up.
So, I think that we must have
met every singe possible member
of Frank's extended family
while we were there,
and I know that you're not
meant to pick favorites,
but I couldn't help but fall in love a
little bit with his grandmother, Bibi.
LAUGHTER
SPEAKING IN SWAHILI
Her and Frank were both kind enough
to show me and my mum how to make ugali,
which is a very simple and
common staple food here,
and it's basically just flour and water
heated up a bit and stirred. That's it.
I quite liked it, honestly,
but as you can probably guess,
it's not exact going to
fulfill your "five a day."
Sometimes, they're able to have other
more nutritious things with it.
We had some dried fish,
but vegetables work as well,
and if they're really lucky,
they might get some meat,
but even then, maximum that
they get is maybe two meals a day,
and that's just based on what
they can get their hands on.
For me, the experience
of going to the villages
was a little hard to get
my head around, honestly,
because, compared to
what I'm used to,
they really don't have
that much, but, as a result,
they're so incredibly thankful for
everything they do have in their lives.
They're so happy despite all of the
hardships they have to go through,
and it's just so inspiring
and so lovely.
I just feel incredibly honored that
I got to meet all of these lovely people
and that they invited me into their
lives with such open arms,
and now I just don't want
them to have any problems.
Anyway, that's just
the first two days.
I've done so much more stuff on this
trip including getting food poisoning,
which I have now, yay, so I'm going
to save the rest for a second video.
Until then, asante sana.
Thank you very much, and I will encourage
you to check out enoughfoodif.org
if you'd like more information about
all of this while you wait for me.
That's all. Goodbye!
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
UKULELE PLAYING
♪This is my face♪
♪On my head♪
♪On my shoulders♪
♪With eyes♪
♪And a mouth♪
♪And a nose♪